there was filming underwater on
partially built sets and in completely
empty rooms the final two harry potter
films created surprising practical
effects had people substitute for
magical creatures and disguised any
evidence that could give away the fact
that much of what we ended up seeing
wasn't real at all just working on it i
get excited being like oh my god i can't
wait to see what this looks like
which professor is that
charity burbidge didn't have an easy
time in the films only actually making
an appearance briefly at the end of the
whole saga filming in the castle the
actress was replaced by a big red x her
filming time was spent quite literally
floating upside down in a green room
honestly far from ideal in both cases
how many potters does it take to screw
in a light bulb who knows but it takes a
lot of different actors on a set to
bring them all to life each actor had
their face mapped out digitally so the
transformation into a potter could be
brought to life convincingly and
honestly kind of creepily cruising
through london brought even more
adventures in cg land where much of the
footage was created from scratch so the
team could capture all the mayhem they
needed in a way that was safe for the
actors involved
what happened where are the others
you'll want to run the other way
the dementors are completely cg designed
and thank goodness because we'd never
want to run into one of those disturbing
as they might be the detail with which
they were brought to life is impressive
they were built from the skeleton up
designed to move gracefully while
looking deteriorated if it weren't for
the soul-sucking part they might
actually be kind of beautiful
mcgonagall said it best
our school
the epic attack on hogwarts only saw
some characters actually being filmed
the giants had their own time on the
practical green screen bridge and as for
their facial expressions all that was
captured up close as reference for the
cg the statues and dementors they all
got layered in after being animated by
the vfx team
it opens at the close harry floating
above him on a wire instead of with
wings only to be removed in editing and
replaced with the cg version speedy
wings and all until radcliffe gives it a
kiss as for when it does open layers on
layers bring that infinity stone to life
ghosts get their own filming time kelly
mcdonald and radcliffe never really
shared the stage mcdonald filming her
portion solo so the vfx team could give
her a ghostly appearance we doubt the
green stick marker was a better scene
partner than radcliff would have been
though the harry potter actor shot his
portion alone as well with each actor's
footage layered together resulting in
this haunting and intimate moment
just how cold was that water for the
most part this was the real deal cg only
being used to remove the rope wrapped
around and pulling radcliffe beneath the
ice and the extra bits of underwater
details like the bubbles and motions
throw a cool filter on and they are set
it was here
oh yeah
let me help you something
on set it's terrifying but in a
different kind of way nagini is less
intimidating when filming but two green
arms darting out to take radcliffe down
is still pretty shocking the cg team
worked on building their snake that was
compiled of layers of design to make her
look as realistic as possible
wands at the ready for the most part we
saw the magic really happen layers of
light and glowing details brought the
magic visually the cg team really outdid
themselves for a lot of these shots and
they made sure mrs weasley was well lit
for her big moment as well no matter how
big or small the spells were the
designers for the special effects made
sure they fit into the world and that
the backdrops in the scenes suited as
well the performers acted hard but the
wand action was all thanks to the vfx
crew
everyone joined for the attack on
hogwarts a blank slate one layer of film
captured of people actually running and
then we bring in the giants
they did a solo green screen filming
session and were filmed closer up so
when the footage was combined the
proportions all made sense
this is a place of business and total
chaos while parts of the set were built
and some details included for the actors
to work with most of what we see is just
the result of hours of work and
inspiration from the cg team not a
detail was overlooked we can actually
see each individual tile on the walls
for the actors it was green screen's
galore the studio ceiling wasn't nearly
as magical or daunting as what we know
the ministry to be though even the up
close bits had tons of cgi and there was
always a green screen insight oh sad
long story
even snape knows not to mess with
mcgonagall a green screen window an
empty space and pristine but subtle cgi
to start the fabric like sweeping away
image was fully animated layered and
blended with actual footage of snape
whipping himself away and out the window
do what you have to do i'll secure the
castle
number 13
plunging underwater like this is an
undertaking but instead of flailing in
the middle of the lake they were in the
studio with green screens in the
background instead of mountains it
wasn't as pretty but it was definitely a
touch more comfortable
and now everything just feels
disconnected
number 14
say it ain't so the trees were great
okay well some of them but the backdrop
wasn't quite right green screen base cg
moody background and giant floating
gravestone yeah much easier to let vfx
take care of this magic fortunately no
caskets or michael gambins were harmed
in the making of
when he's mad you know it
rae fines got to act out his moment just
to have everything but his face and
torso removed because his flowing and
floating body were added layer by layer
by layer one last layer of fog detailing
and lighting for good measure and voila
is there anything more satisfying to
watch rae finds did an excellent
dissolving into fragments face but there
was no face leaving in this case just
some blue and green dots for the cg team
to track and use for editing in post
gone to find that face amp up the
unhealthy looking color cgi can be nasty
the stage is set it was covered in
rubble and dirt and fines and radcliffe
were ready to give it their all
but the stage didn't quite look the same
classic green screen backdrop but about
half of what we see is pretty much what
the team saw on the day
with a big dash of glowing wand light to
amp up all the drama
the quidditch pitch is burning down or
is it the field outside of hogwarts was
far from fiery everything from the pitch
to the flames to the many people
surrounding it
you guessed it all courtesy of detailed
and intricate cg how far down does the
staircase go sorry to disappoint but
it's actually just a couple of levels on
the upside it's a much safer setting for
the actors to work on some of the
practically built set transitions
straight from stairs to ramp and even
some of those final details got some
touching up and editing it made for a
less crowded day on set as well most of
the students were just made by cgi
software
it's obvious isn't it
we have to talk to someone who's dead
the room of requirement really can be
anything hoards of stuff was piled and
filmed and everything but the stuff was
removed and replaced with a full cg
design space oh all that fire cg
creations to the max with every detail
of the burning flames covered through
layers of computer-generated designs
that make up the images of nagini and
voldemort we see
it's the snake
this is the last one
it's the last horcrux
below zero not so much
alera frost or layer of cgi either works
in this case every tiny frozen detail
gets the cg treatment and luckily the
crew got to keep a bit warm other
cold-looking landscapes were much less
intimidating looking pre-cg as well
the newspapers held in their hands were
real the moving photos well not so much
a green square and a piece of paper can
be anything when cgi is involved
dumbledore was captured by the camera
crew and then the vfx so slickly
superimposed that image right onto the
newspaper and voila living pictures
number 23
we thought there were loads of trailers
on these lots but turns out all they
needed were a few close up vfx layering
took care of everything from the shape
of the land what vegetation was on it
and of course making all those visual
duplicates of the countless trailers
that bag goes deep it wasn't endless
though needs to
change was sticking her hand straight
through a hole in the bag only to have
her arm blacked out in post this is when
low lighting comes in very handy anyone
can have a bottomless bag if there's
just a hole in it
we love a guitar store but it's not so
on brand as nice as the actual backdrop
of the late night resto scene is it
wasn't going to cut it with all the
random people walking by in traffic but
the dark and moody backdrop that gets
layered over top give it a bit of blue
and it does the trick the landscape on
the train ride needed some adjusting as
well gotta balance those colors subtle
but effective
they finished it the way they started
only a handful of takes were done to
capture this magic on the set daniel was
ready to go all in and rafe joined him
making for some very intense fighting
which all happened to be filmed while
the actors were literally hanging upside
down and hooked onto wires both actors
were a mess after the fact rey finds
even shed some blood one second they're
here and the next
how do i look
hideous
apparating seems easy when it looks like
this but the cg team went through plenty
of work to make this moment happen
filming together each actor's body was
edited separately so they could all be
brought back together in the final image
as they become that signature swirl
that's right
it was being stupid
the final two hp films brought some of
the best cgi there is it's pretty
impressive especially considering what
it looked like in the early days
which scene were you most surprised with
cgi
[Music]